Samsung
Naomi Osaka is trading tennis rackets
for baby rattles yep the 25 year old
tennis pro announced she's expecting her
first child Naomi shared the news on her
socials posting this ultrasound of her
little bundle of joy along with a sweet
message I have so much to look forward
to in the future one thing I'm looking
forward to is for my kid to watch one of
my matches and tell someone that's my
mom
and that will hopefully come next year
Naomi's post also included her promise
to fans that she plans to get back on
the court in time for the 2024
Australian Open this will be her first
time playing since 2021 when she made
headlines withdrawing from the French
Open citing her Mental Health
thank you
okay I think we're just going to take a
quick break just uh we'll be back in one
moment
at the time she shared an emotional
statement writing the truth is I have
suffered long bouts of depression since
the US Open in 2018.
Osaka was referring to an Infamous match
with Serena Williams Naomi defeated the
superstar in front of a booing crowd
she's beating her Idol she's won her
first Grand Slam it's she's made history
for Japanese tennis
so I just want to tell you guys she
played well and this is her first Grand
Slam let's give everyone the credit
where credit's due and let's not move
anymore no more booing
but Naomi wrote in her pregnancy
announcement these few months away from
the sport has really given me a new Love
and appreciation for the game I've
dedicated my life to
so fans can look forward to seeing Naomi
tear it up on the court again in 2024.
but in the meantime we'll be cheering on
Mama Osaka as she welcomes her first
child with rapper corday and while we
don't know the pair's current
relationship status they keep things
under wrap we do know they met in 2019
at an LA Clippers game where and when
was our first kiss
what yeah I remember I remember I'm
being funny what you call it it's the
spot in the desert
you know what I'm talking about
you know them Indian Wells right yeah
[Music]
foreign